that's like two things in here that you
don't really want to ever go bad
combined with alcohol is here everybody
that talks about it likes it there's
eggs is it really eggs in it why am i
drinking is that Jameson this reminds me
of like the only food that Teletubbies
have what oh no I don't like that smells
like pancake batter actually I'm really
into that it kind of tastes like um some
sort of medicine it's very thick I'm
miss brandy do you remember the
Cinderella that brandy was in Oh smell
better
they'll just smell kind of sour and
sweet love it oh that was better this is
holiday spirit I feel like rum is like
known to be like the best pairing away
yeah this is gonna be great this is
romantic
no super into it it sounds cute eggnog
what's nog I don't know but it's cute
so like sure you want to try it but I
did not like how that tasted I think the
Christmas spirit came inside me and I'm
full of it now whiskey was definitely
pairs nicely with the good old eggnog
I'm not gonna go out and buy it
round brandy and then whiskey not to be
confused with a singer Koosh then
shooting at the world
what get it there got it
yeah it's here